well the title of your book is rebuild a
dream yes what what does the title mean
why the why what did you call the book
well I felt that the American dream of
for lack of a better term which my dad
really lived I mean he was born and
segregated poverty he joined the
military so that he could get out of
that situation then he put himself
through college
he put his little brother through
college he put a cousin through college
but me through college my sister through
college and he really got his whole
family into a middle-class life that's
the American dream his dreams are pretty
modest but he was able to achieve them
and I looked around and I saw people who
maybe like my dad were disadvantaged or
maybe had been in the middle class up
until a couple years ago really
struggling now and I felt like we needed
to do something I want to write about
what happened how we had this big
movement for hope and change 2008
elected the first african-american
president a progressive president
champion of the people and yet there's
still the sense of now almost going from
hope to heartbreak in the country so I
want to write something about that and
of course having been a grassroots
outsider for most of my life and then
being a White House insider for six
months and then being an outsider again
I thought I had maybe a 360 degree
perspective on some of the ways that we
were not achieving some of the change
that people had hoped for what why now
why put this book out now instead of you
know at the end of a term in the
beginning of a term kind of in the in at
the end end of the first term well I
mean in some ways the first term is kind
of over just because it seemed doesn't
seem like Congress is gonna do a whole
lot there's some things that Congress is
likely to do but I think that right now
is when people are trying to make sense
of the Obama era so far you know I
passionately believe in this president I
believe he's gonna be reelected I
believe he deserves to be reelected but
I think we also have to learn that just
voting on one day and then kind of
hoping you know the vote at hope
strategy it's not gonna be enough to get
the changes done so I wanted to while
people are thinking about politics while
people are thinking about how do I
assess what I just went through the past
three years the past four years
and think about the next four I thought
it'd be a good time for me to share my
perspective how did being in the White
House for those months how did how has
that changed your perspective from being
an outsider being in and then being out
and we'll we'll discuss how what
happened but to make you leave a little
later but what what exactly how did that
change your perspective well I believe
that I have a little bit more empathy
and sympathy for people who were in
those positions I know a lot of the
grassroots progressive left which which
I hail from feels just almost disgusted
with DC and just disgusted with the
White House I mean I when I go out in
the road I do a lot of talking and
teaching and that kind of stuff you hear
a lot of very negative assessments and I
don't think there's enough sensitivity
some of the things they want the
president to do would be illegal if he
did them not the king you know there
there are rules and regulations and so
and you have a sense of that but really
when you're working inside the White
House I mean everything has to fit
inside the four corners of the law you
have legal counsel all the time
everything has to be done exactly the
right way and if you just start
deviating from what the law requires
just based off of your own perspective
or preferences or ideology you can get
in a lot of trouble that's not what the
White House is supposed to do and so I
think that people expected this
president to be able to do things that
would literally not even be allowed by
the law and and and weren't willing
often to do the hard work of continuing
to build public will and a Congress of
this president could work with do you
feel like and you you've been you were
critical of Democrats or falling down on
the job
for years why isn't Obama a part of that
and secondly why isn't he part of the
political elite that have that you sort
of have failed to help the middle class
and you know help everyone but the one
percent yes well I criticize Obama to
people asked asked about the book you
know is it a pro Obama book is an anti
Obama book it's a pro analysis book I
mean I really felt like a lot of the
books that I saw being written about the
Obama era being wit written
this moment in history we're falling
into what I call like the DC trap so
everything can be explained by the
politicians and the political operatives
and the pundits and the polls but we the
people aren't in that story the people
are just sort of polling data or
precincts or a public opinion but people
have real movements and people work to
make change in a democracy so I thought
it was important to write a book that
took people's movements seriously so the
movements that elected Obama how did
they build over time Obama didn't come
out of nowhere 2003-2004 what was
happening also the Tea Party movement
which seemed to come out of nowhere well
it's his origin how did it work
Occupy Wall Street I thought those were
important things to to take seriously to
look at for my social movement We the
People perspective on how change happens
in Washington DC or how it doesn't in
writing that I have a lot of criticism
of the president and of the White House
in the book and I talked about ways and
I think that the president could have
it's been tougher on Wall Street from
the very beginning failure to do that
open the door for the Tea Party and open
the door for Occupy Wall Street so the
two big movements that challenge him in
his presidency are in some ways a
response to what was a perception of a
tepid response to some of Wall Street's
crimes and misdemeanors so to speak
let's get into what he could have done
what were some of the solutions you
proposed on on Wall Street sure well I
just think that I'm not alone in this I
think that that just giving them free
money and hoping that they would act
better just a lot of it was paid back I
think I think that's good but there
weren't enough conditions on it in terms
of making sure that they repaired some
of the damage to the American people for
instance you have a lot of homes that
are underwater because back during that
fantasy bubble period their homes were
being way over evaluated well now people
are being way over charged for those
homes something could have been done to
make sure that that people homeowners
got more relief than they got a lot of
the banks right now are sitting on a lot
of money
small businesses are still not being
able to access capital the way that they
should maybe that could have been some
programs put in place to kind of help
jumpstart our small businesses again
I'll
a lot of things could have been done in
that moment so that Wall Street could
help Main Street Main Street bailed out
Main Street bailed out Wall Street but
then Wall Street didn't really turn
around and help Main Street in the way I
think people thought would have been
there so though that would have been I
think a very smart thing for the
President to do I also think that the
President did good things from a policy
point of view but then didn't get
political credit for him for instance
with the stimulus I talked about in the
book in the stimulus he got a 787
billion dollar stimulus 1/3 of it is tax
cuts for Americans Republicans and
Democrats like tax cuts ok yep that's
some crazy wild ringer oh yeah well the
idea nobody knows that most people think
Obama raise their taxes he cut taxes for
ninety five percent of America's nobody
knows that the other third another third
was for states and cities keeping cops
on the beats because when we when we
when we went down hard and if we had if
every state had to follow its budget
when we went down that collapse they had
to layoff teachers firefighters nurses
first responders a third of that
stimulus was keeping cops on the beat
and kindergarten teachers helping your
kids nobody knows that so the stimulus
which is actually something was
successful at least in terms of
quote-unquote saving jobs you created or
saved he saved you your kids teachers
jobs nobody knows so those kind of
mistakes it's like even when you do the
right thing and you don't know how to
get the credit for it that demoralizes
people and so I think that both sides
could have performed better not
surprisingly outsiders and insiders the
book is an attempt to help us and learn
from those mistakes so we can go forward
what about something it's something like
the Bush tax cuts it's something that I
he's kept thus far yeah is that and it
was it was a dress but it wasn't
directly the fact that he he's like he's
those have continued yeah I think it's
time for those to go away especially for
the for the wealthiest people in America
the good thing about being an American
is if you have a business idea if you're
an entrepreneur if you're an innovator
you can get out there and you can do a
bang-up job first of all you don't have
to pay any bribes anybody they have a
permit you can just go get your business
permit if you have a product you can
get to market on the road you didn't
have to build that road the taxpayer
built that road you can hire employees
you can have to teach them algebra the
taxpayers if that would public schools
you cut on the water the water is clean
now have to pay for a filter the
taxpayers do that so the taxpayer does a
lot the America the American people are
the anchor investor in every American
enterprise so when they if American
Enterprise doesn't do well you got to
pay anything back if you have low taxes
but when you do well in America you
should do well by America you should be
proud to pay your taxes pay America back
keep that system going so the next
person can come and use those roads and
use that internet and use all that stuff
that you didn't have to buy yourself and
that return on investment for the
American people isn't is violated when
you give massive tax cuts to the people
at the top then the people that top can
benefit from America but then they don't
have to pay at miorica back well then
you wind up with deficits and you also
wanted was a middle class and free fall
so I think at the end of this year when
the Bush tax cuts expire especially for
the wealthy it's time to let the wealthy
pay America back they got the benefits
of the bailouts and the bonuses and the
tax breaks for a long time that should
time should be over he was not tough
enough on that from my point of view the
first part of his presidency rule kind
of helped I think it doesn't the Buffett
Rule is pushing in the right direction
and I think what's amazing is you take
somebody who's Warren Buffett who's
first was known as is a fantastically
wealthy person who's smart and wealthy
but he wasn't a political he didn't
represent a political idea but Obama was
able in this is part of his genius to
draw a connection between a wealthy
person everybody knows and loves and
respects and his secretary you can
imagine in your mind if you never met
her and used that very simple
relationship to tell a whole story
now that's Obama at his best and so you
know he's done some things well he's
done some things poorly but the
grassroots we did not perform at the
level that we should have and some of it
is because we were mad at him but some
of it is because I think we had the
wrong idea about what his job was
I say the book LBJ did not lead the
civil rights movement that was he was a
head of state that was great he signed
those those laws but you know fannie lou
hamer mm-hmm Bayard Rustin dr. King Ella
Baker those grassroots leaders were the
ones in Selma and the ones in
Mississippi and the ones who were
pushing forward to give that president
something to respond to and I think that
after the inauguration a lot of people
not everybody but anybody but too many
of us sat down and thought that we had
passed the finish line when really that
was just a starting line November 2008
the environment is another place for you
you waged some criticisms what are you
what's your take on the what's happened
at the Keystone pipeline start off bad
got better now looking bad the Keystone
pipeline is a really bad idea that's my
that's that's that's my assessment it
would as initially proposed take the
dirtiest most awful scraping the bottom
of the bucket nasty poly carbons tar
sand and then run it down through
America's heartland over farmland over
aquifers choose a gulf coast so that it
could be refined and shipped to China we
wouldn't get any of that oil but more
importantly because because of the kind
of toxic stuff it is it's very corrosive
so you'd be very just like we've had a
lot of oil spills up in the in Canada
you would really be risking America's
beauty and the health and safety of
American people to do it to benefit a
foreign corporation selling dirty oil to
China
well they say well you gotta have em
thousand thousands of jobs but then it
turned out that the numbers were cooked
and it's not that many jobs you had some
temporary jobs which are important for
those workers but the permanent jobs are
very few and so from my point of view it
wasn't worth it
and because it's a southern part of that
of that pipeline sure so so the there's
the southern part of their building
there are apparently some choke points
that existing oil production could they
could be facilitated without having to
go and get the dirty stuff from from
Canada so that part which was never in
dispute it wasn't the actual claim was
that though the aquifer and the farmland
was going to be put at risk because of
the route of the pipeline and because of
the kind of product so the placement of
the pipeline and the toxicity of the
product was going to jeopardize farmland
and one water ographers
well was never true about the southern
part if it was no tar saying you don't
have a problem with the product and if
it's you know in that part of the other
of the pipeline there's no aquifers so
he could go ahead and prove that and
help other parts of oil production
however the good thing about this
particular development it shows once
again people-powered movements can make
a difference it was people powered
movements that elected Obama he was not
the favorite of the Democratic Party
establishment at first people powered
move its change that people powered
movements through the tea party
challenge the president and then with
the Keystone the young environmentalists
350.org and some the Native American
groups and Bill McKibben challenged the
President to say look at this pipeline
don't don't just go along just give it a
good hard look and they used civil
disobedience and protests to call
attention and I think that did play a
role in him reevaluating what you say
that the the network around Obama didn't
didn't help or didn't die he didn't do
it
instead of him not doing enough they
didn't do enough what else could they
have done I mean what what else could
have been done in the last you know
couple years sure
well a couple things first of all in
most countries when the right wing
marches and you would have to say the
tea party is a right-wing populist
movement that would be how you would
describe that from an academic point of
view a right-wing populist movement most
countries when a right-wing populist
movement takes to the streets protesting
then the left-wing marches to you could
have you know to protest for two years
you just saw massive Tea Party protests
and there were some progressive
demonstrations but they were not
coordinated in the same way they did get
the same visibility they were not in
success
and many of them frankly were just very
small and the Tea Party movement has
small protests they had large protests
but they were coordinated and they
really used that grassroots street heat
to change the conversation you didn't
see progressives really try to mount a
serious response even as late as the
midterm elections you still hadn't seen
any serious streaking
I think Democrats and progressives
thought that because we had the white
house the house with Nancy Pelosi best
speaker ever and 60 votes in the Senate
that's all we needed
I think we thought we had a hundred
percent of what we needed to govern and
I think actually we had a third that's
only a third I think you also have to
have a media operation sort of like Fox
News I think it plays a very strong role
for the right and you have to have a
grassroots movement the tea party was a
grassroots movement so we thought we had
a hundred percent we had 33 percent and
the people who we thought had zero
percent had 66 percent and when they
wound up being able to stymie the agenda
and win the midterm elections and I
think we have to learn from that
you can't just vote you also have to
peacefully protest to demonstrate be
involved in your community and you also
have to have a better message for the
media is it fair is it a fair criticism
you criticize the environment the
environmental lobby for not getting
behind cap-and-trade enough they spent
millions of dollars I mean they weren't
they weren't just on the sidelines
is that a fair criticism because I mean
you've got your lobbyists a lot too and
both sides everybody has a lobbyist sure
sure
well with regard to the cap-and-trade
obviously I was somebody who's a big
champion for cap-and-trade and I was
actually in the White House when we were
able to pass the first part of that
through the House of Representatives in
the book where I am critical is after it
stalls in the Senate and we can't get
cap-and-trade done now let's be clear
cap and trade was the consensus position
of both political parties when Johnny
ran he ran saying climate change is real
caused by humans here and saying
cap-and-trade is the right market
sensitive mechanism to deal with it
and he ran saying it'll create jobs the
only thing both obama and mccain agreed
on was climate change real caused by
humans cap-and-trade gives you jobs a
lot of people in his party did not agree
with that sure but but to be clear this
theater barrier for their party did did
agree with that and he never ran any ads
attacking obama for his position on
climate and clean energy in fact he
spoke very favorably of and it was
important point for mccain now it stalls
in the Senate the Republicans have now
gone a hundred eighty degrees other
direction in lot in lockstep saying they
cap-and-trade which is their proposal
from the Heritage Foundation cap and
trade the Liberals were more interested
in either direct regulation of carbon or
even a carbon tax cap and trade was a
conservative position Obama goes with
that position
it still stalls in the Senate I'm
critical of myself first and the
environmentalist when the oil spill then
happened in the spring of 2010 there was
another moment to say hold on a second
let's relook at energy policy in America
should we be subsidizing companies that
are risking our health immediately in
the long term we didn't do it you've
never seen the environmental movement
more quiet doing an oil spill if you're
- you've John McCain a bit president
with that oil spill or George Bush had
been present with that oil spill I'd
have been out there with a sign
protesting I didn't because the flew the
president was well that's a bad that
that's not good for the earth it's not
good for the cause it's probably not
good for the president it's certainly
not the way that we should conduct
ourselves and so I'm very tough on
progressive movements and leaders
including myself who did not stand on
principle based on who we looked across
in size president there was a Gallup
poll that was released just a couple
days April 9th I'm so about ten days ago
and the one of the things I thought was
interesting about it was that in 2007 a
lot of Republicans were overwhelmingly
supportive of a lot
the lot of the issues we're talking
about but by by four years later they're
not it's mostly it Democrats are pretty
much stayed the same Republicans have
dropped why do you think that is is it
the partisanship is a what what happened
there because it there was there was
some support for some of these efforts
you know in 2007 yeah I it's
heartbreaking to me because it people
say well maybe there's too much
partisanship but I don't see too much
partisanship uh if you mean both sides
are equally partisan and equally dug in
just so that they did that the magnets
are moving apart yeah well it's funny
because in some ways the magnets are
moving toward this the right but just
the Republicans are moving faster for
instance I'm a progressive Democrat the
president is a moderate Democrat I would
have said on health care single-payer I
would have said on health care why do
you need private insurance companies for
health care insurance is what you buy if
you're not sure about the outcome maybe
you're gonna have a flood maybe you're
not you buy flood insurance because you
don't know right well everybody knows
that some point you can see a doctor
even if you get run over by a Mack truck
you see at least a doctor's gonna
pronounce you dead everybody's gonna see
a doctor why do you need insurance for
that from my point of view progressive
Democrat point of view single-payer
would be the right answer well almost
all Democrats have been in that position
trying to move to a more port bipartisan
stance so we arrived at the public
option some some people be a Medicare
for the people who wanted Medicare for
everybody who wants it if not you can
have a private insurance company to
trying to be bipartisan the public
option was declare too far to the left
so we moved again we're not being
pressured then we move to the individual
responsibility mandate which was the
Republican point of view that
individuals should take responsibility
not the government well then they
abandoned that and they say that that is
is not acceptable and so here we are so
that they become sore like the pro
freeloader caucus you know just die bomb
you're talking to the emergency room the
governor I'll take care of it like
that's bizarre
and so what I see is
is actually moving further and further
to the right it's just that the the the
conservatives are moving further to the
right faster and so that creates this
very strange dilemma do we keep just
chasing the bunny around the bar or do
at some point do we just say well listen
these are our principles this is what we
believe
let's stand up for them and maybe the
American people will agree with us if we
quit changing our position trying to
chase this bunny and but it is very
heartbreaking on issues like health care
like clean energy and energy
independence and others that had been at
least some common ground possible you
saw some common ground possible it seems
to have just eroded and and I don't
think it's good for the country I don't
know the the best answers but I try to
put some for it in the book you said
that the by the summer of 2010 that the
health care fight was over did you ever
imagine that it would be we'd still be
talking about the health care bill and
that that you know the Supreme Court is
deciding on this this is it was far from
over in 2010 that corrected quickly but
you know there's another example maybe
if the progressives who like myself who
believe in single-payer had stood our
ground longer maybe that public option
would have looked more like it what it
was a real compromise Supreme Court
might have been more friendly to a
health care bill that said okay listen
if you want to buy health insurance
privately go ahead if you don't you got
to pay for the public system just like
you pay for public roads whether you
like it or not you pay for public roads
whether you like it or not you pay for
public schools so whether you like or
not you're gonna pay to pay to the
public health system there may not have
been a grounds to object to that but
because we gave away the public option
where you could either go the option a
competitive option you could either go
with the private system or you could go
with a with a public choice then now the
Supreme Court has a well
can the government just make someone
bypassed though I mean well that's the
thing about it is part of what happened
was it was his deflation among
progressives when this massive Tea Party
movement started showing up everywhere
had we argue in the book had we started
marching too had we had our own concerts
and rallies and that sort of thing and
gotten more people involved maybe we
could have gotten a better deal but
instead we got more and more into the
sausage-making not the movement making
in the heartland
but the sausage-making the deal cutting
in washington DC which even made people
more depressed he had the corn huh where
the corn Husker thing and all these bad
little sweeteners and just nasty stuff
and so then of course it's hard to get a
good deal because your base is
demoralized people are confused some of
the principles either single-payer or at
least public option have already been
jettison so then you wind up with a deal
that maybe doesn't inspire and spread
your mate in fact the worst thing you
could say about some legislation is when
it depresses your friends and outrages
your enemies may be rated to that how do
you think it'll hurt the president if
this if this goes down if the supreme
court decides that a piece of it or the
whole thing it's hard for me to say
first of all I don't think I don't think
supreme courts going to strike the whole
thing down and I I think that they will
find a way to keep most of it intact I
think health care is a bigger deal for
the political class or the health care
bill right it's a bigger deal for the
political local class then for working
middle class people I think people are
concerned about health care people on
both sides are confused about what the
health care bill even is or does so no
matter what thing the Supreme Court
actually does it'll be interpreted
through filters people think that the
health care bills already kicked in and
full of facts people who don't like it
and you don't like this president think
it's already kicked in is already in
full effect it's already causing all
these problems but most of it hasn't
even kicked in yet and so how will they
respond to the Supreme Court I have no
idea and then you have progressives who
of course are very defensive of the
President and how will they respond but
I think the economy not any surrogate
for the economy but the economy is going
to be the real the real decision-maker
for people well the the the tea party
was of course very against the health
care yes the health care bill to say
you're not a fan I respect I respect
their achievement but we don't we don't
agree right how much of your view of the
tea party came from your experience why
you left the White House is that was it
was your view of them colored by that
that experience I don't have to be yeah
yeah yeah
I try in the book to be fear to their
achievement it's a phenomenal
achievement if you have no vote that we
get essentially a filibuster proof
majority against you in the Senate which
they had if you have Pelosi running the
house who's a strong proud liberal and
you have Obama in the White House you
have not drawn a bunch of good cards to
make change in Washington DC and they
found a way to do it and so you have to
respect that
no matter what side of the aisle you're
on you have to respect that and part of
my criticism of people on the Left is
that there was quick dismissal of them
and not appreciating what they were
going to be able to achieve however I
don't agree with their version of
American history I don't agree with
their assessment of what America's
values are and I wouldn't have agreed
even if I hadn't become a poster boy for
their all their anger and frustration
but of course having then been the
target of it I was you know have a
special insight into it a social
awareness of it and kind of feel a
special commitment of myself just stand
up against those ideas I don't agree
with them you say they punked the world
yes why well where does that come from
well yeah well I mean it in the Aston
Kutcher
yeah they they made themselves to be to
appear much bigger and much more
ferocious and much more fearsome than
they in fact worth early protest though
they were pretty big sure but you're the
left it puts on protest that big without
you know ban and I this I tell you what
they were especially brilliant those big
protests that you're talking about late
August and then in September 2009 it was
an August and they were still little
that they made themselves look big they
would send three or four or five people
to those town hall meetings August 2009
there'd be a hundred people there
supporting President Obama and three or
four of them who weren't but they would
grab the mic and they would be so loud
and so passionate that the TV camera
just couldn't help but focus on them and
that that's really what I'm talking
about they were able to early on create
the impression that everybody who was
going to those town hall meetings was on
their side because you saw it on the
news he saw a whole bunch of people and
some were yelling and it looked like a
whole mob of people it turned out when
in fact most of people were there to
support the president or to find out
more information or to complain about a
pothole or whatever they were there for
and it was brilliant theater on their
part and then that that spiraled but
here's a deal they 150,000 people coming
to Washington DC to march for the tea
party at that time ofa the president's
organization had 13 million members so
literally if you know a quarter of those
people had marched it would have swapped
the Tea Party protests but that was a
sense well we're not gonna March we're
just gonna get the legislation done and
I think that was a mistake because it's
psychologically made of course huge
achievement but it looked even bigger
because there was no response
but 2010 you saw a lot of I mean it
wasn't it wasn't resonate well then I
mean it wasn't just people showing up in
Washington yeah right buses you know it
was it was there it was all around the
country but by then by then it sort of
it's sort of like anything else if if if
you meet something when it's small
then there's an outcome if you wait and
let it get bigger and let it get bigger
and let it get bigger and you don't
respond to the charges the worst charges
they made against the president we're
not responded to that he's some sort of
atheist Muslim communist socialist crazy
things of course how can you be a Muslim
and an atheist like no Muslims have to
pray five times just like these crazy
charges those charges were not I think
properly dealt with but more importantly
humans you know they see large numbers
of people coming out for something
whether it's a rock band or NASCAR or
something you think oh that's very
popular and then if nobody's coming out
for the other side do you know what
they're not popular and so I do think
that in DC we talked about the
subcommittee's and the legislation and
again the sausage-making
and we sometimes forget ordinary people
they're not tracking all the stuff so
closely mm-hmm all they see is a lot of
people in the streets are mad at the
president he must have done something
wrong mm-hmm in 2011 you challenged
Glenn back to a debate yes are you you
clear I don't regret saying that and is
the offer still open oh listen I keep
saying a good limbic talks about me but
he won't talk to me and and I think the
people who watch glenn beck they should
I should ask him listen why won't you
talk to van he says only way I'll talk
to Van Jones if he confesses that he's a
traitor and I look whatever crazy crazy
things well I'm not those things so I
can't confess to that but I mean I would
be happy to talk to him at any time part
of the problem that we have is that you
have people who live in their own
information bubbles just the mere fact
that I've read most of the books about
the Tea Party and actually listen to
Rush Limbaugh and that kind of thing I
have a lot more insight and to what is
appealing about the conservative
movement the right-wing movement then
most of my liberal and progressive
friends who just say what was in that
stuff I won't even read that stuff
mm-hmm well isn't that what progressives
accuse conservatives are being
close-minded of not being open to other
views well aren't we doing the same
thing and so I think that I I am I'm
passionate in my beliefs I don't
apologize I'm a progressive Democrat
proud of it I don't pretend that I'm
something that I'm not but I also am an
American and we're democracy we have a
lot of different points of view in this
country and we have to listen to each
other we don't have to agree the other
thing I think we have to do I want to
beat my opponents I'm looking I'm not a
conservative so when the conservative is
writing I want to beat him fair and
square right fair and square
just like with my kids playing soccer I
want my kid to win but if your kids
played against my kid I want my kid to
beat your kid but I want my kid to kick
your kid or bite your kid I want my kid
to win fair and square so we can either
be passionate in our partisanship but
still have principles and not lie on
each other and not mistreat each other
and part of the challenge we have right
now is that things have gotten to a
point where that's very hard to maintain
that things get very heated
we all miss peak sometimes I certainly
have misspoken at times but I try to
maintain the basic view that we're one
country and we can disagree but and I
want to be job well I've got great
friends Republic as every day every
times lecture I want to beat you fair
and square and and the problem with the
bright parts a lot of stuff that I've
seen Glenn Beck do is there seems to be
a lack of honesty and forthrightness and
fairness and how they characterize
people to challenge my patriotism to say
you know that I'm a threat to my own
country and my father was in the
military yeah I'm glad he it doesn't
happen he's passed away but yeah I would
have hated for him to have heard this
kind of thing being said you know this
I'm you know it's it's not the right way
to have the discussion I write in the
book actually about what I call the
difference between deep patriotism and
cheap patriotism and I think it's
important that the deep patriotism of
liberty and justice for all
and for all meaning everybody you
include and lesbians in gays and I don't
leave anybody out
that's deep patriotism America the
Beautiful and defend America's beauty
against the clear cutters and the oil
spills and the mountaintop removers
that's deep patriotism respect the
sexual
but also respect the principles that
there's a poem written on the base it
says give me your tired give me your
poor that's about the immigrants who
came to this country you can't be an
anti-immigrant bigot and a patriot at
the same time deep patriotism is you
love the statue you also love the
substance of what that statue stands for
can you have the opposite view though of
what you're saying and still be have a
deep deep patriotism I mean can be the
opposite end of the spectrum and still
be a deep I want to I want to challenge
the view that you can have a
reductionistic simplistic view of
America's values attack other people is
not being Patriots it but then not be
challenged yourself see the problem is
liberals and progressives usually don't
want to raise this question of júlio of
what patriotism is because we want to be
tolerant of everyone but then what
happens is some people on the far end of
the right will then use our silence on
these questions and say well we don't
love our own country and then we get
challenged and we said well these people
are not patriots and I'd say well why do
you want to have to debate we have
something to say about that we have our
own view of patriotism we have our own
way of enacting America's values and
responding to America's value and we
hold them very dear and if you keep
challenging us and saying that we don't
believe then fine let's have the debate
and then out and and at the end of the
bait we'll we can shake hands and figure
it out but I'm not afraid anymore to to
say now listen I didn't start this fight
but if you want to say everybody who is
a liberal who's a progressive is against
America then you then we're gonna talk
about what it means to be for America
and I think we're gonna come out looking
better than some of the people who have
been attacking us all this time
we we talked a little bit about the the
games that the tea party made in the
2010 election and what has and they've
changed the Republican Party in a lot of
ways the debt ceiling used to be a vote
that was I checked the box that ceilings
raised we all go on and it is no longer
what has you talked a lot about Occupy
Wall Street and it's
there are them in the spectrum for you
you like them a lot what have they done
that for the Democratic Party that's
that is not tangible but is is a real
measure of change that they've made sure
a couple of things if you remember in
August of 2011 the Tea Party politicized
that vote around the debt ceiling and
said that they were gonna crash
America's credit rating if certain
things weren't done
I reject reacted that was shock and
dismay as I did a lot of people and part
of the compromise that came out of that
standoff was this idea of a
supercommittee that was going to have a
lot of authority and was going to ram
through a lot of cuts and that was I saw
that is a really big threat to America's
middle class working class people
because I know what they were gonna cut
and it was gonna go on super super fast
so my organization rebuild the dream.com
Starr trying to gear up you could spread
the alarm we gotta do something about
this those Occupy Wall Street young
folks who have no lobbyists who have no
PACs who have no you know candidate just
went down to Wall Street not even in
response to that but just because they
didn't call recall for it but just out
of frustration what was happening and
they change the conversation overnight
no one was talking about economic
inequality no one was talking about
really Wall Street's
role in everything anymore that was kind
of you know off the table
they changed the conversation it's even
Republicans headed to talk about
economic inequality which i think is a
good thing but more importantly the
supercommittee just disappeared I mean
the conversation changed so much between
August and October the prep time we got
to November nobody wanted to do any of
the things that had been so fashionable
in August because it would have been
going now in the face of public opinion
which had gotten very much more concern
not concerned about debt deficit cut cut
cut but what's going to happen to
Americans when it comes to jobs and why
is Wall Street getting away with having
done all this terrible stuff with the
country and they got more bonuses and
other people have less money inflation
also deadlocked the entire time from Dan
and the Democrats stood their ground the
Democrats that had been chasing that
bunny for two years stopped chasing it
and parties they stopped chasing it is
because Occupy Wall Street and the
entire discussion happening globally
suddenly about I gave a lot of strength
to Democrats you saw the president began
to talk you probably was going to talk
in a more populist way anyway for the
campaign but he had more space
Washington DC changed it was on an
autopilot for austerity and those young
people with no no lobbyists no PACs no
candidate changed the discussion in the
nation's capital the strongest country
in the world
that is an incredible achievement for
you know basically a bunch of unknown
young people and struggling folks so I
think you've got to give them the credit
for that
but here's the downside of it the tea
party write about this in the book the
tea party they went from protest
politics very quickly they were in there
out there protesting and then they're
registered voters and then they
participated in primaries and they
supported Scott Brown and they got Teddy
Kennedy's old seat in Massachusetts in
the Senate broke that filibuster proof
majority senator who's voted with
Democrats at times that's true certain
things that's good but at the time it
was the tea party was a key ally for him
and they did an extraordinary job they
went from the energy of protest which is
important they converted that energy
into political power and then they were
able to begin to implement their agenda
not always in DC sometimes stopped here
but in state houses across the country
that is an incredible achievement from
my point of view Occupy Wall Street
their center of gravity is very
different they are march that in direct
democracy and direct action they don't
want to register voters and participate
in that way so that's that's maybe meant
that they have less impact long-term
than they might have otherwise however
that's their choice the rest of us
though who are not occupiers but who are
concerned about the 99 percent need to
find ways to begin to fill in those gaps
and that's what rebuild the dream.com I
won the organization I'm a part of the
ordination I helped to lead is focused
on so you're saying are you saying that
the the Occupy Wall Street just kind of
run its course at this point no no
there's always going to be a role for
direct action and direct democracy and
that movement in particular yeah so so
they will continue to make contributions
and who knows they're so creative and
they're all over the country so who
knows what they'll come up with but I
just mean that they've already made it
pretty clear that they don't want to
register brothers for instance there's
an analogy you can make with Occupy Wall
Street that they're sort of like the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee back in the sixties those
young people exactly they occupied the
lunch counters they occupy the
segregated buses the difference though
between sneck and occupy is the snick
youth also helped the Mississippians
occupy the voting booths they ran voter
registration and voter education
programs so they did the direct action
which Occupy Wall Street has done but
they also did direct voter engagement
that's would be the model for the 1960s
the occupiers they they don't want to do
the for the registration part so that
does leave a gap it's not a criticism of
them they have the right to do what they
want what they will and I don't speak
for many where I speak up for them
balance before but there is this now
this gap how do you turn all that energy
into some political power how do you go
from anger to answers how do you not
just change the conversation but change
the conditions under which people in red
states and blue states are living that's
what's left to be done in the next term
that's what this books about I've been
challenged just a little bit about on
this on other occupiers because it there
was a poll you cited USA Today poll in
in the books of course I'm gonna look it
up and that that particular poll it was
in November 2011 poll and debatably when
occupy was at the height of its 36
percent of americans didn't really have
an opinion of them and so I mean I how
poignant could that movement have been
if their I mean you know at the height
of the movement that not a lot of people
really even you know didn't like them
didn't dislike and we're kind of yeah
well I've seen other polling data that
suggest other other things I said that
one could you use
I appreciate it
but the theme if you look at the opinion
data on the themes that they have it
that they popularized it's a night and
day kind of an impact the idea of
economic inequality the 99% versus the
1% nobody was talking that way now you
can talk you can say that pretty much
anywhere and in political conversation
people know she's talking about those
things are hard to pull off if you're
just a bunch of young people with
sleeping bags in tents I mean I think
it's hard this is not the Occupy Wall
Street is not the same as a tea party in
that the chi party very quickly was able
to get the support of Fox News very
quickly was able to get the support of
Americans for Prosperity and other
groups that are funded by the Koch
brothers and which is their right to do
but they were able to come up with a
better alignment on the Tea Party side
between the protests the protest wing
and the establishment wing and the
Occupy movement that's not it wasn't
baked into the DNA with Occupy so when
you can when you consider again no PACs
no candidates no money no lobbyists they
have that kind of an impact on the
political discussion so we're sitting
here talking about them now and it's
whatever is April it gives you some
sense of their impact so with oh I know
it's gonna ask all right you talked
about the 99% talk about Occupy Wall
Street
what is the difference because I think I
think for a lot of people who haven't
read this book they think it's the same
thing then because the we are the 99% of
course was a rallying cry for the Occupy
Wall Street movement was on the placards
everywhere well I think that you can
make a distinction and I can almost
logically you or if you think about long
as you kind of have to make a
distinction Occupy Wall Street those are
the people who are the occupiers they
basically went down there they slept
outside so I'm got pepper-sprayed they
went to the General Assemblies they did
the mic checks you know they did the
hands
they did all that sort of stuff you know
you do the math that's probably
quarter-million people across the
country was frankly that's a significant
number of people but if you look at the
polling data in terms of the themes they
articulate it's about a third of the
country agreed with them that's a
hundred million people hmm.well hundred
million people didn't go down and get
pepper spray I mean like that that's
clearly uh another grouping of people
not 99 percent literally but in terms of
who agrees about a third of the country
well hundred million people that's kind
of like the civil rights movement in
terms of that those large numbers
everybody wasn't going down there
protesting but a logical felt that they
were they wanted to see some changes
happen in America
so I say snick the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee the young
protesters are alike the occupiers
mm-hmm but the ninety nine percent
movement is much bigger much like the
civil rights movement you could be in
the civil rights movement but not be in
the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee
you could be in the civil rights
movement and not be in dr. King's
organization and not be in the
n-double-a-cp it was a much bigger
movement any one organization and so I
make the case in the book that it might
be smart for us to think about the
ninety nine percent movement as being
much bigger than just the small number
of very important dedicated occupiers
well let's get to what your group is
doing what so you want to try to turn
this into a the 99% into a political
operation even from the local level on
up yes how are you gonna do that well
it's funny it's already well underway
okay which is exciting
rebuild the dream.com is a is one
organization and a broad coalition of
organizations and who just so we know it
works for it the the present incarnation
is called 99% spring mmm-hmm and it
includes afl-cio moveon.org SEIU the new
bottom line organization which is a
bunch of low-income groups people of
color groups that have been challenging
the bank's the Domestic Workers Alliance
a lot of progressive organizations and
the idea is to begin organizing people
to be able to take nonviolent direct
action to be able to peacefully protest
but also to know what's wrong with our
economy and how it could be made better
how we could go back to the things that
worked for us in the last century and
you know that would so that is a process
that we're a part of now there are some
organizations that we've been working
with like progressive majority like the
campaign for america's future and others
like the Working Families Party that are
recruiting candidates to run for office
and we've been able to successfully
recruit thousands of candidates at the
local level and to be able to support
them all the way up into the
congressional level so what kind of
positions are we looking at where you
say local level is it Sheriff is it oh
well a city council school board okay so
now that I say from doggcatcher to
Congress I don't know if anybody's
actually writing it for dog and the
great thing about that is that it lets
people get involved and we have this
rebuild the dream.com has something
called the contract for the American
Dream and we interacted with a hundred
thirty one thousand people one hundred
thirty one thousand two hundred nineteen
people to be exactly okay all across the
country to come up with some good ideas
to get America working again you know we
think if you put it put the country back
to work you can pull the country back
together and so the contract for the
American Dream has ten key ideas
including fair taxes green jobs save
Medicare and that becomes one of the
basis by which people who agree that we
could go in a different direction can
find each other interact again 300,000
people signed on to it but a hundred
thirty one thousand people helped to
write it so there's a lot going on and
the book tries to capture this social
movement people powered politics that's
going on I think a lot of books about DC
get caught flat-footed because well
Hillary's gonna be the nominee Senator
Clinton's gonna be the nominee and she
had been a great nominee and then Obama
comes out of nowhere and then Obama was
the president he can do whatever he
wants to whether the Tea Party comes out
of nowhere
well the Tea Parties means we're gonna
have austerity forever that Occupy Wall
Street comes out of nowhere the people
we
the people are impacting the system and
it's not a left-wing period it's not a
right-wing period it's a turbulent
period of change and we don't know what
the outcomes are going to be but we do
know that people powered movements are
going to continue to have an impact and
the book is about that and rebuild the
dream.com is about that are you trying
to lay the foundation for a third party
I think well I'm not I mean I think that
the Tea Party has it right they're not a
third party and when I say Tea Party
they don't even mean political party
they really mean like the Tea Party of
old but they're inside and outside the
Republican Party so they can function
independently when they want to but they
also can be inside the fold when they
want you progressives have nothing like
that if you're a strong progressive
liberal Democrat like myself we don't
have that equivalent yeah you're either
in the Democratic Party or you're not
and so I do think that we need a strong
organized left wing of the Democratic
Party in the same way that the
Republicans have a strong organized
right wing represented by the tea party
I think if we had a little bit more
balanced some people say well there's
too much partisanship already and I say
no there's too much excessive right wing
partisanship I've seen two little
partisanship on the part of Democrats we
keep chasing the bunny down the road and
we've abandoned our principles on too
many things for too little of - too
little gain and so I think we need some
of us who go ahead and stick up for our
principles loud and proud happy to have
the debate and then if a deal gets cut
at least it's being cut between two
positions that are clear and principled
and not between one position that is
unyielding and another one that's you
know available to be moved without any
clear benefit is it going to be
difficult though to corral these people
because they do they've got a lot of
different interests they have a lot of
different Rajasekhar Occupy Wall Street
but you have your the casualty groups
that you they would make good members
instead of this group and they were
Millennials veterans homeowners
long-term unemployed and public
employees all of these people are gonna
have a lot of different interests how do
you corral them into one
I know you're not trying to put them
into one box but into one mission well I
think that part of it has to do with
what we were talking about earlier how
did we build the middle class mm-hmm
did the medical with no class was it a
gift from big corporations was it the
result of just every individual just
doing whatever they wanted to just like
you know their economic liberty above
everything else with with no
responsibilities to the community or
with no respect for America's government
or was their debt another formula was it
the best of the individual doing their
very best but also the best of America's
government where we could all pull our
resources and invest in the country and
invest in the next generation plus the
best of our business sector see I think
the American middle class was was
created it's a the best invention in the
world is the American middle class
because the whole world saw it and they
started trying to duplicate it and but
it wasn't there's a myth that says you
know government is not the solution
government's the problem governments
always bad America's government is this
horrible thing America's government
can't do anything right I don't feel
that way America's government sent some
very good things America's government
was the way that we built the
infrastructure from the from the
interstate to the Internet America's
government is the way that we educated
generations of Americans who were able
to out-compete the world America's
government and and and and all those
governments that she shelters state
local and tribal is a good guy from him
and now it's got some bad parts to it
says everything else but you can't
disrespect America's government and say
America's government has no role and
should be starved
Grover Norquist we want to cut taxes so
much that we can shrink America's
government to the place you can drown it
in a bathtub that's not a patriotic
statement I don't feel that way about
America's government so I think usually
how do you corral people you tell the
true story of American people the
American Century that this century
everybody celebrates unions had a role
the government had a role the individual
had a role markets had a role all of
these different parts of America had a
role and you can't just take a wrecking
ball paint it red white and blue and say
I believe in individual liberty
therefore I'm going to smell
- down every other American institution
from public education to unions and say
that's the right way to way to rebuild
America I disagree with that and I think
if you put two stories side-by-side one
that's a true story of what our
grandparents did for us they did well
individually but they also were a nation
and neighbors and they pulled their
their money through government to build
the best country in the world and they
respected America's government if you
put that story against we hate America's
government America's governments always
a problem we don't want to pay any taxes
to America's government I think you can
get a lot of people together that's what
we need to do finally what is the and I
know it's book packed with different
issues yeah what is the message you want
someone who you're you want to read this
book to take away from it I think the
most important thing I can say is that
politics is not just what happens in
Washington DC that we the people make
the movements that make DC work and so
it's not about vote and hope anymore
we've got to be post hope the book is
probably going to be mostly
well-received by you know moderates
progressives independents Green Party
people the people who are who are a more
Center and and left we got to be post
hope we got to be that vote and hope it
vote in March vote and get involved
we've got we've got a big democracy
deficit that's opening up we've got to
deal with it we got to get big money out
and more people into politics and we got
a budget deficit we got to deal with it
with a hundred percent of Americans not
just a 99 percent paying the freight
thank you very much oh thank you for the
opportunity appreciate having you thank
you